[Musique]
qui est-elle
non non Brad a parlé ce matin dans la
salle de bain et soi-disant elle est une
célébrité et soi-disant elle a tué son
petit ami avec elle nue est yo ouais je
vais regarder ses cheveux lâchés
tu pourrais dire qu'elle shampoing c'est ouais
quand comment va-t-elle faire passer ça
[Musique]
bien bonjour
Kim Kardashian blanc quel est ton nom n'est
pas ci
-dessous laisse-moi regarder ce que tu as vu bien tu dois en
fait d'où tu viens du Canada
oh je suis des amis viennent de Barriss oh
chanceux G eh bien sis toi un  célébrité et
tout, pouvez-vous nous dire ce qui se passe vraiment
avec Kim Kardashian et Jerusha parce
que j'ai besoin de savoir que G je ne sais pas si ce n'est pas
son meilleur ami ou quoi que ce soit, je suis le météore Wong
il y a quatre ans
oh mon dieu tu as rencontré Kimberly pas bien
kardashian-west  tu es la femme à qui
j'ai une question très importante qui
gagnerait la bataille royale des culs lady Kim
kardashian-west ou Nicki Minaj
comme des citrons citrons et du fromage hé n'aie
pas peur d'elle maintenant
c'est lui je donne une contrebande dans
frères qui oh il  llo je veux dire tes
cheveux sont magnifiques et tu n'utilises pas
bonjour bonjour bonjour
ils ont fait beaucoup de ce slogan je
dis j'adore j'ai acheté un livre j'ai
peur maintenant
coupe moi je ne sais pas ce
qu'elle a de talons  parler de j'essayais juste d'
obtenir des produits capillaires sur le percocet et
était résistant n'a pas servi la chimie waka Masaru
l'ensemble de défaut connaît un
peu la Corée seulement totalement vide
Idlewild avec pas de connexion à mr.  Caputo
un visualiseur de musique L'aïkido ne doit pas le laisser
près du Litchfield certains hajima du désert
aucun concours seul le collège de l'AB a reçu
seulement pouvez-vous du bon métro d'Omaha
[Musique]
SSST Susie uniquement des batteries sur Haysom
pinatas attitude sur l'
arbitrage de la piscine de bonbons croisés sur quoi avec le  drame
le chemin meilleur névrome qu'ils ressentent pour
Patty moi
alors commençons peut-être à faire face à la coupe, vous
devez voir le premier problème et
partager souvent ses mamans EC sur chaque faisceau de
sauvegarde quand ils espèrent que vous avez besoin d'un
cas ouvert d'université net sur la gravité gagné '  t
flotter ou préférer une plante pourrait manger bien l'
arbre en effet un mr horrible.  pikna - dans
tous les sens
[Musique]
La Scala nouvelle solution super simple
[Applaudissements]
Message unique de la catastrophe du bureau de poste Ilia
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
nous avons vu un espion connaître un animal de compagnie de guerres de
wha
[Musique]
vous